now to georgia where an investigation is
underway into a deadly liquid nitrogen
leak at a poultry plant
six people died there and a dozen more
were hurt three of them critically
manuel borges reports from gainesville
georgia where there's a claim that
employees had warned about this leak
we have a nice leak in here we have some
people down inside
panic set in at the foundation food
group plant in gainesville just after 10
a.m thursday
firefighters arrived to find several
people with medical emergencies
in and around the facility five
employees died at the scene and a sixth
at the hospital at least 130 employees
were taken from the plant
to a nearby church to be evaluated where
people like brenda aguilar
frantically searched for missing loved
ones we're just praying he's okay
he's just one of the ones that's injured
and they just haven't gotten his
information to let us know he's
okay but we also know that
that could not be the case aguilar later
learned her uncle
who worked at the plant had died liquid
nitrogen is used for refrigeration
when airborne it's an odorless gas that
can displace oxygen and cause a loss of
consciousness
cbs news has learned members of the
company's leadership
knew there was a nitrogen leak on
wednesday but did not want to close the
plant for a day
to fix the problem our hope is that
this tragedy did not happen in vain
cindy benavidez is ceo of the league of
united latin american citizens advocacy
group
many of the plant workers are latino
every single day you have
so many in our community who wake up to
go in
to a poultry plant or meat packing plant
or pork plant
to be able to feed the entire nation
this was probably
not something that anyone was expecting
the foundation food group has called
this a quote tragic accident and cannot
say with certainty at this
point what went wrong we reached out to
the company about the claim that
management knew about a leak but at this
point have not yet
heard back anthony tragic for sure
manuel thank you